here's a flower come on there's a flower
i just gave you flowers
love and hip hop atlanta star jocelyn
hernandez
made an appearance on wednesday's
episode of the wendy williams show
and things got tense we agree to
disagree
the 34 year old tv personality came on
the daytime talk show to chat about
season two of her series
jocelyn's cabaret atlanta but things
quickly went south
shortly after wendy started the
interview
miss wendy i i just must say this to you
first
i hope you're going to give me my
flowers today i hope you're going to
honor
how much work i put out there i'm an
accomplished woman
and i just feel like every time i come
to your show you don't give me
those flowers now you know and you're
wondering you're 35 years my my city oh
yeah actually
i should i should get those flowers i
should
feel i should feel i should feel wanted
by people like you
wendy tried to assure jocelyn that she
finds her very entertaining
but jocelyn wasn't convinced we feel
like you'll be trying us
we feel like you don't be really voting
for us you know
we feel like and especially with me
every time i come on your show you'll
always want to compare me to another bra
i don't need to be compared i've made my
own brand i'm i've made my own brand for
years you know
i've been out here for the past decade i
got my own show i franchised
my own show to another network it's i
had the number one show in the country
that's when wendy chimed in to fact
check her guest
the number one show on zeus and you got
renewed for a third season
the number one show in the country it's
okay
the reality tv star went on to say she
feels undervalued
and wendy she said the feeling is mutual
every time i come on here you feel
undervalued well so do i
okay that's it you know what jocelyn
because you're part of pop culture this
is what i do
but if you possibly think that i leave
here every day and don't feel
undervalued for something that i do
you know as a woman we're not gonna even
talk about race just as a woman
i still don't make that dollar for
dollar men make so please anyway shoe
cam please let me see your shoes
but it didn't stop there like really
like are you serious
the two went tit-for-tat and at one
point
wendy threw an actual flower at
jocelyn's screen
here here's a flower come on there's a
flower i just gave you flowers
she even asked the producers to call it
a day on the segment anybody
disrespect can we just pull the plug
what is going on
jocelyne jocelyne yo y'all let me tell
you you know
that i feel like this tell him that no
yeah he told me that you yelled at him
the whole time the producer on the phone
but by the end of the interview the two
appeared to be on better terms
you were here before me i don't want to
take your spot i just want
i just want to do what i do you want
your fair share of the pie and you're
getting it
jocelyn my puerto rican princess good
luck with everything you really have
always been a go-getter with that drive
to make it on your own
so i trust that it won't stop as for
wendy
etie caught up with the talk show host
in january and she shared that she
landed a multi-project deal with
lifetime and she hopes to teach a course
in communications in the future
i like doing something besides this talk
show because this is not going to last
forever
and being on tv in front of the camera
is fun
i love doing this but i'm realistic and
i know it's not going to last forever
i would like to go into the classroom i
would like to be a professor
i feel as though people are sending
their kids to college and for four years
you're being taught by a bunch of
professors and teachers who haven't even
done
what your kids are studying to do so
i would like to get into that classroom
action and i would like to actually
start doing that before the talk show is
over and then keep it going
you know forever get in that classroom
talk to these kids be the professor not
a lecturer for one day but
teach a course in the communications
department
because the parents pockets deserve that
you